andre leon talley has died he was 73
years old you know in the hard times we
live in women want to buy things wet
first they want to be seen they want to
feel good they want to know that they
have
bought a look that makes them stand out
andre was a celebrated editor and
creative director at vogue magazine
throughout the 80s and 90s and a
groundbreaking figure in the lgbtq plus
community i've never seen the disasters
on the red carpet i um
i'm always looking for the best stress
and as i said i'm looking also for the
people who are
going to try to be mutual prada or
rihanna oh so good to see you
good to see you oh my goodness
andy cohen reacted to his death while
taping watch what happens live
andre was he just was such an incredible
life force i mean when i think of him he
just was boisterous he was bold
he was lively we loved having him here
he had a booming voice
he just gave so much energy and love to
everyone around him
at all times and he really was a
trailblazer long time friend and
colleague diane von furstenberg shared a
tribute to instagram writing quote
goodbye darling andre no one saw the
world in a more glamorous way than you
did no one was grander and more soulful
than you were the world will be less
joyful i love you and i know you
andre was a frequent staple on the red
carpet later in life oftentimes joining
e.t as a fashion correspondent while
talking to the stars
you had a couple of my dresses in there
i was very flattered in his final
interview with e.t andre shared his
biggest career highlight during his time
at vogue
my proudest vogue moment was
to have been assigned to do the first
interview profile on michelle obama when
she became the first african-american
black first lady
i went to washington
in
december before the inaugural i was so
proud and i only wish my grandmother who
raised me had been here had lived long
enough to see me that cover it sits on
my coffee table in my living room that
is my proudest moment
you